des exploits scientifiques les plus
impressionnants du 21e siècle
on exploie réaliser la semaine dernière
dans ce laboratoire californien de
l'énergie a été produite grâce à la
fusion nucléaire une avancée
technologique qui pourrait être
révolutionnaire faut juste prendre
l'été on va nous faire le numéro à
chaque fois là là vous avez vu c'est
terrible il faut boire attention on va
tous mourir oui il va faire chaud les
étés on le sait mais il va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec c'est comme ça
l'humanité c'est l'adaptation c'est pas
terrible
fusion nucléaire il y a pas de déchets
de ce type là c'est un peu comme si on
pouvait utiliser non pas de l'essence
dans le réservoir de notre voiture mais
de l'eau une technologie propre son
risque d'accident nucléaire qui ne
génèrent aucun gaz à effet de serre la
fusion permet également de produire une
quantité d'énergie sans précédent c'est
la réaction qui aliment nos étoiles
comme le soleil sur Terre ce processus
peut être obtenu grâce à des lasers
ultra puissants qui génèrent une
température de 150 millions de degrés
sur les rivages du bassin d'Arcachon la
dune du Pilat en toile de fond ses
amateurs pratiquent le longeco une
randonnée aquatique et sportive
réalisé par tous les temps ce jour-là 5
degrés dans l'air 12 degrés dans l'eau
loin de décourager ses joyeux lurons
besoin pour ma tête et pour moi ou quoi
j'aime ça
je suis un peu Alexis même beaucoup à
l'excès certains diront
ouais genre je reconnais que c'est
beaucoup et le comédien Bruno Kremer
dans une interview il ne faut jamais
oublier que la télévision n'est qu'un
appareil électroménager et enfin Gérard
Depardieu dans une interview avant il y
avait les mouches maintenant il y a la
télévision les ados il y a quand même un
chiffre 23 % des 15 17 ans passe 7
heures par jour tu vois un écran 23 %
c'est encore on parle de d'études
sérieuses compilés etc 23% plus de 7
heures je peux vous dire que c'est
beaucoup plus que ça j'en suis sûr alors
j'allais dire pour les autres
dans le dos selon Reporters sans
frontière le nombre de journalistes
emprisonnés dans le monde a atteint un
nouveau record en 2022 ils sont 533 soit
une quarantaine de plus que mon dernier
où l'on a enregistré déjà un niveau
historique 57 on était tué dans
l'exercice de leur fonction enlever par
un groupe djihadiste notre confrère
Olivier Dubois et détenu au Sahel depuis
le 8 avril
2021 décédé l'année dernière à 97 ans
elle est glace de 40000 euros à sa
commune le maire décide de faire une
surprise à ses administrés et rédige
cette lettre attaché à son village elle
a décidé de nous léguer son assurance
vie et regarde
sur terre
c'est ton petit cadeau
c'est pour te
donner du courage
[Applaudissements]
on était parti sur le maître sur un
projet communal quoi mais bon après on
réfléchissant vu le contexte économique
énergétique et tout ça on a dit que
peut-être un coup de main un petit coup
de pouce la population mais ça serait le
bienvenu 159 foyers reçoivent ainsi dans
leur boîte aux lettres un chèque cadeau
de 100 euros
donc là vous mettez un petit peu de sel
[Applaudissements]
cette photo suffit à alimenter la rumeur
d'une grossesse de Kate Middleton le
cliché de Noël partagé sur le compte
officiel du prince et de la princesse de
Galles sème le doute des internautes se
demandent si elle est enceinte quand
d'autres convaincu la félicite
directement waouh je le savais tu es
enceinte félicitations prudence ce n'est
peut-être qu'une histoire de robe de
position des mains une pause typique de
femme enceinte ou tout simplement
d'angle de prise de vue
la ville entière diassante et d'or
le monde s'endort dans une chaude
lumière
là tout n'est corde ribotées
calme
et volupté